ich fahre durch die grüne will der
küstenlandschaft nordspaniens durch berg
und tal am meer entlang in einem der
luxuriösesten züge der welt
eine exquisite reise die an die goldene
ära der eisenbahn erinnert
mit erlesener küche und spektakulären
landschaften
einfach nur schön doch die raue
landschaft fordert zug und zugführer
alles ab
so knapp
atemberaubende natur faszinierende
technik willkommen an bord des trans
canada breko clasico
[Musik]
die reise beginnt am verschlafenen
bahnhof von san felice nicht gerade
standesgemäß für ein fünf sterne hotel
auf rädern
meine erste reise nach nordspanien und
das in diesem wahnsinns zog
die zug besatzung hat nur wenige stunden
zeit um den luxuszug reisefertig zu
machen alles muss perfekt sein sowohl
drinnen als auch draußen
ist der cheftechniker des trans kantable
co
wir müssen ein brems ventil auswechseln
der zug arbeitet mit druckluft bremsen
und die ventile steuern den luftdruck
dieses hier verliert luft
[Musik]
dort managerin anna maria sutil hatte
den kommenden acht tagen das sagen an
bord darf ich um ihre aufmerksamkeit
bitten dies ist unser team auf dem
transparent apricot die passagiere
zahlen zum teil mehr als 5000 euro für
die fahrt mit dem luxuszug und
anna-maria sorgt dafür dass alles klappt
[Musik]
die 36 reisenden werden von einer 13
köpfigen crew umsorgt service wird hier
groß geschrieben
unsere kellnerin
geht es allen gut sehr schön
das ist meins
großartig ein tolles abteil das ist eine
schmalspurbahn die waggons in daher
nicht sehr breit aber der raum ist
optimal genutzt worden dass hier klappt
man runter und fertig ist mein bett
luis corrons ist der heutige lokführer
wir prüfen jetzt die bremsen der zug
fährt erst los wenn louis und samuel
grünes licht geben wir machen eine
sichtprüfung
die bremsen müssen auf der bergigen
strecke perfekt
funktionierenden bremsen sind gecheckt
die diesel elektrische lok an der spitze
des zuges ist drei meter 70 hoch zwei
meter sechzig breit und 14 meter lang
mit
1550 psc 13 wagen einen generator wagen
eine küche eine bar samt tanzfläche ein
restaurant ein barwagen noch ein
restaurant und sieben schlafwagen
insgesamt 400 tonnen muss die lokomotive
vom fleck bewegen
vor uns liegt eine anspruchsvolle
strecke es geht steil bergauf von wieder
runter
die passagiere starten ihre reise mit
einem prickelnden gläschen cover einem
spanischen sekt
willkommen an bord des 20
so muss eine bahnfahrt anfangen
[Musik]
alles bereit maschinen starten
alles bereit alle an bord
und los geht's
die tausend kilometer lange reise führt
auf einer strecke aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert von san felice bis nach
bilbao
dann entlang der zerklüfteten biskaya
küste hoch in die kantabrischen berge
und wieder hinunter bis zum zielbahnhof
verón
[Musik]
die strecke führt von einem tal ins
nächste dort sind die bahnhöfe es ist
ein ständiges auf und ab in die berge
und wieder runter ins tal
die reisegeschwindigkeit liegt zwischen
30 und 50 km h mehr geht nicht denn die
spurbreite dieser längsten
schmalspurbahn westeuropas beträgt nur
knapp einen meter also ein drittel
weniger als bei einer normalen spürbaren
[Musik]
in der schmalspur müssen wir langsamer
unterwegs sein können wir zu schnell in
die kurve fahren wird's gefährlich
anders als bei anderen zügen ist
langsamkeit in diesem zug erwünscht die
reisenden sollen dem stress des modernen
lebens entfliehen und die fahrt genießen
unterwegs werden ihre handys keinen
empfang haben und wlan gibt es auch
nicht heller soto ist reiseleiterin an
bord nur so können sie die reise und die
wundervolle landschaft auch wirklich
genießen
ich bin rund um die uhr für die
passagiere da wann immer sie
missbrauchen ich bin anspricht
doch nicht nur die atemberaubende
landschaft nach dieser reise so
besonders auch kulinarisch ist der trans
kantable clasico ein genuss
die gastronomie spielt bei dieser reise
eine große rolle das essen an bord ist
besser als draußen
ich habe hunger essen wir in der kleinen
bordküche zaubert chefkoch andres
palacio ware gourmet gerichte sie
spiegeln die esskultur der jeweiligen
region wider die der zug gerade
durchquert
unser heutiges hauptgericht ist gott
chinas kurz zeta mit couscous und
trockenfrüchten
[Musik]
dessert servieren wir karamellisierte
tory h mit haselnuss eis
heute fährt der zug die historische la
rubia linie die in der gleichnamigen
stadt beginnt
wir überqueren den turin fluss auf einer
stahlbrücke aus den 1800 90er jahren ein
stabiles bauwerk und eine von 18 drücken
auf den ersten teil unserer reise nach
bilbao
trotz des unwirtlichen terrace wurde die
330 kilometer lange bahnlinie einst in
nur dreieinhalb jahren gebaut
überwiegend per hand von der heimischen
landbevölkerung
stahlwerks besitzer finanzierten die
strecke um kohle aus den nahegelegenen
groben abzutransportieren
schmalspur gleise eigneten sich besser
für die gewundene und bergige strecke
weil sie billiger und leichter zu
verlegen waren
liebe gäste in fünf minuten servieren
wir ihr abendessen gut 120 jahre später
ist von der mühsal vergangener tage an
bord nichts mehr zu spüren
man ist hier sehr stolz auf die
hervorragende küche und die tollen weine
die in diesem prächtigen speisewagen
serviert werden edler geht's fast nicht
küchenchef anderes nimmt die ovationen
für sein erstes dinner dankend entgegen
[Applaus]
in der alten bergarbeiterstadt sistieren
legt der zug den ersten übernachtungs
stopp ein
zug hält bremsen sind arretiert
während zugführer luis corrons seinen
arbeitsplatz verlässt macht sein kollege
samuel einen letzten kontrollgang dann
ist feierabend
morgen wird ein harter tag wir haben
einen steilen anstieg und eine
schwierige abfahrt von st
am nächsten tag geht es bis auf 1000
meter hoch den höchsten punkt der
strecke
[Musik]
die kurvige strecke verspricht
fantastische ausblicke
[Musik]
der zweite reisetag beginnt sonnig und
blauth zeit zum aufstehen
um acht uhr morgens läuten wir die
glocke und öffnen die rollos das ist der
startschuss für das frühstück
das ist was ganz besonderes
kein vergleich zu modernen zügen
großartig
luis corrons macht den luxuszug
startklar zuerst löst er die
feststellbremse
nach zwei jahren auf dieser route sitzt
jeder handgriff kinos liebt seinen job
den sonnenaufgang mal den
sonnenuntergang
für mich ist das ein traum
nach kurzer fahrzeit steht heute der
erste ausflug auf dem programm es geht
zu einem der vielen tourismus highlights
in der region die man am besten per bahn
erreichen kann
ich schaue mal unter den begonnen
doch die abfahrt verzögert sich
wir haben hier ein kleines problem auf
der hauptleitung ist kein druck samuel
guckt sich das jetzt an ich schätze eine
druckleitung ist gebrochen
ein problem denn die bremsen arbeiten
mit druckluft
wir müssen das reparieren
samuel verdächtigt das brems ventil das
er gestern ausgetauscht hat
schon mal nach
der zug hat bereits verspätung samuel
wird nervös
druck es in ordnung dass ventile sticht
alles normal
das neue ventil funktioniert einwandfrei
doch irgendwo tritt luft aus
die zeit verrinnt
schauen wir nach siehst du was soll ich
mal gucken
wir sollten längst unterwegs sein aber
wir sitzen fest wenn sie das nicht
hinkriegen brauchen wir einen plan b
[Musik]
wir wollen die römische villa la ola
besichtigen
und louis keine ahnung was ist es gut
ich bitte einen fahrer herzukommen
keine nostalgische bahnreisen
stattdessen ruft anna einen bus der die
passagiere zur römischen villa bringen
soll
serrano wir sind in system der zug ist
kaputt
derweil haben louis und samuel den
fehler gefunden
das bremssystem verliert luft wir wissen
jetzt wo können aber erst weiter wenn es
abgedichtet ist
doch die reparatur der leitungen
gestaltet sich schwierig
erstmal muss dieses teil raus das wird
dauern
der kommt gleich
reise leiterin heller soto begleitet die
passagiere während anna sutil die
stellung hält
[Musik]
am späten vormittag erreichen die
zugreise denn schließlich gezielt die
2000 jahre alte villa almeda eine der
bedeutendsten archäologischen stätten
spaniens
diese römische villa ist 4400
quadratmeter groß bei dieser größe kann
man sich leicht vorstellen wie mächtig
besitzer war und sie viele musicals gab
ist weltweit einzigartig
die magie dieser städte macht die
probleme des vormittags vergessen
faszinierende ruinen
am bahnhof von city arena ist die
leitung inzwischen repariert
[Gelächter]
der erfolg dieser zugreise ist immer
eine teamleistung aber heute hat vor
allem samuel einen super job
endlich kann es weitergehen
[Musik]
der leere zug fährt zum nächsten bahnhof
um die passagiere wieder einzusammeln
doch auch ohne sie muss die lok auf
diesem abschnitt ganze arbeit leisten
das ist ein sehr schwerer anstieg die
maschine muss mit maximaler leistung
verantwortlich dafür ist das über 400
kilometer lange kantabrischen gebirge
dass diese tour zu einer der
anspruchsvollsten bahnstrecken europas
macht
es gibt viele spitzkehren da sind wir
höchstens 40 km h schnell und müssen
extrem vorsichtig sein
der bahnhof von la spina ist mit fast
1200 metern über dem meeresspiegel der
höchste punkt der strecke
[Musik]
diesen teil spaniens nimmt man españa
werde das grüne spanien die wenigsten
kennen diese naturbelassene und
waldreiche gegend
doch die strecke hat es in sich um
sicher über die berge zu kommen müssen
die züge der linie 7 care schleifen
bewältigen der trans kant apricot müht
sich in serpentinen das gebirge hinauf
innerhalb von drei stunden bezwingt der
zug sechs pässe
erst dann gehen die fahrgäste am
nächsten bahnhof wieder an bord
[Musik]
ist willig ist die schwierige fahrt hier
zu ende aber zum glücklicher alles gut
die lok hat kaum zeit zum verschnaufen
doch zum glück für die maschinen geht es
diesmal bergab
dieser gegend ist höchste vorsicht
geboten denn genau so steil wie es
vorher bergauf ging geht es jetzt
hinunter
[Musik]
der trans kant apricot hat den bahnhof
von matt apolda erreicht und wird für
die rückkehr seiner fahrgäste
vorbereitet
wir lüften machen die betten putzen die
bäder
alles muss fertig sein bevor die gäste
zurück kommen
nach einem langen ausflug gehen die
passagiere wieder an bord
anna wir sind hier in magdeburg er war
die passagiere sind zurück an bord alles
okay ich denke alle sind zufrieden ab
hier übernimmt josé fernandez das steuer
ein eisenbahner aus leidenschaft
ich liebe meinen job ich bin zwar nicht
mehr der jüngste aber ich will weiter
fahren solange es geht denn ich liebe
den job
doch selbst für einen alten haudegen
virus ist die bevorstehende drei stunden
abfahrt eine herausforderung
loks wie diese werden manuell gesteuert
bei modernen zügen ist das anders die
füttert man mit daten und den rest macht
das programm
der technik-check erledigt
danke
ja der zug ist bereit
war der aufstieg ein härtetest für die
maschinen so ist der abstieg ein
dreistündiger härtetest für die bremsen
alles wird per hand geregelt auch die
geschwindigkeit dafür braucht man eine
menge erfahrung
doch für die reisenden zählen nur die
fantastischen ausblick auf der strecke
hier sehen wir den ebro stausee einen
der größten stauseen im land
[Musik]
gerade halten wir auf der bh brücke der
längsten steinbrücke auf unserer strecke
sie ruht auf 11 böden und wurde 1946
gemacht als man den stausee anlegte
wurde das tal geflutet und die schienen
höher gelegt damit der zug durch den
sumpf kam
der stausee ist fast 25 kilometer lang
in der tiefe finden sich die reste von
neun gefluteten dörfern
während die passagiere das panorama
genießen kann die köche in der engen
bordküche
sie ist schmaler als eine normale
das schreckt uns etwas ein
und die zugbewegungen erschweren das
anrichten auf den tellern
schließlich hatte er zog seinen acht
stopp erreicht
[Musik]
am morgigen tag geht es dann in die
größte stadt auf der route
heute geht es nach bilbao dort ende die
rot blauen linie ab da fahren die
richtung westen die küste entlang ans
meer die landschaft da soll wahnsinn
sein
die strecke nach bilbao geht bergab bis
fast auf meeresspiegel niveau dort wird
die lok ihre antriebsart ändern
dies ist möglich weil die lokomotive
eine so genannte doppel lok ist
ich schalte den dieselmotor ab und
kuppel das getriebe aus
dann fahre ich den stromabnehmer aus und
das system verbindet sich automatisch
die umwandlung passiert im innern der
login diesel modus versorgt ein
verbrennungsmotor einen generator mit
energie und der treibt die vier motoren
an
beim umschalten auf elektroantrieb
schließen sich die unterbrecher und die
motoren werden durch den strom aus den
oberleitungen angetrieben
elektrisch fahren die züge billiger doch
die infrastruktur in die berge zu
bringen ist schwierig und kostspielig
oberleitungen für die bahn sind also nur
in dicht besiedelten gebieten sinnvoll
wo sie von vielen zügen genutzt werden
in verkehrsreichen gegenden nutzen wir
den elektrischen antrieb jetzt kommen
wir aus einem gebiet mit wenig verkehr
da würde sich die elektrifizierung nicht
rechnen
während der achttägigen reise wechselt
die lok fünfmal in den elektromodus
bilbao ist eine tolle stadt mit dem
schönsten bahnhof auf der ganzen strecke
ein langer tunnel im süden der stadt
führt schließlich zum bahnhof concordia
eine bau aus dem frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert
[Musik]
dies ist das nördliche ende der linie
samuel hilft beim übersetzen des zuges
auf ein anderes gleis später geht es
dann weiter richtung westen
zog trennung erfolgt
wir müssen die richtung der lok ändern
wir fahren sie auf ein anderes gleis und
aus dem zug ende bild die spitze
jetzt kann der zug in die andere
richtung fahren
mit fast sieben millionen passagieren
pro jahr ist bilbao ein wichtiger
verkehrsknotenpunkt
doch in früheren jahren war bilbao vor
allem ein umschlagplatz für kohle
herzstück des bahnhofs von bilbao ist
dieses bund lars fenster es besteht aus
301 teilen und zeigt was das leben in
nordspanien prägt für schwang
landwirtschaft stahl
einst waren die stahlwerke der region
motor der industriellen revolution
ihr haupt treibstoff war die kohle die
auf der la rambla linie transportiert
wurde
wie das aussah lässt sich an bord eines
alten museums zuges erfahren
nichts geht über eine dampflok
großartig
[Musik]
hier wird geschichte lebendig man fühlt
sich zurückversetzt in die frühen jahre
der eisenbahn
das baskische eisenbahnmuseum hat fünf
kilometer schienen auf dem gelände sowie
dutzende von dampfloks und güterwagen
die einst kohle transportierten
die rodler linie ging 1894 in betrieb
mit über 300 kilometern war sie damals
eine der längsten bahnstrecken europas
[Applaus]
dampfloks verbrennen jede menge kohle um
voranzukommen aber die örtlichen
bergwerke hatten reichlich davon
der heizer musste pro kilometer 18 kilo
kohle laden auf einer einfachen fahrt
waren das bis zu vier tonnen kohle ein
echter knochenjob
die crew nutzte die hitze des dampfes
und der glut um damit unterwegs die
mahlzeiten zu kochen
angeblich half das rütteln des zuges um
während der reise großartige eintöpfe
zuzubereiten
die züge sind derart solide gebaut dass
sie 200 jahre später noch immer
funktionsfähig sind dieser hier stammt
aus dem jahr 1820
doch spanien kann auch schnell derzeit
wird im norden des landes eine
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke gebaut die
nicht über die berge führt sondern
direkt durch sie hindurch
[Musik]
die doppelröhre ist 25 kilometer lang
und ist damit das größte tiefbau projekt
spaniens wir haben hier drei milliarden
euro investiert
früher hätte der bau eines derart langen
und tiefen tunnels wesentlich länger
gedauert denn früher wurden tunnel mit
dynamit in den berg gesprengt
[Musik]
der tunnelbau war gefährlich teuer und
langwierig
heutzutage übernehmen
tunnelbohrmaschinen oder tbm dieser
arbeit sie sind sicher und effizient
eine tbm kann die gleiche arbeit in
kurzer zeit und für einen bruchteil des
geldes machen
nach vierjähriger ausschachtungsarbeiten
können die schienen verlegt werden
die schienen müssen perfekt platziert
werden die toleranz beträgt knapp 2
millimeter die neuen pendlerzüge sind
bis zu 250 km h schnell
der geringste defekt auf der spur würde
bei diesem tempo zur katastrophe führen
2021 sollen über 1200 kilometer
hochgeschwindigkeitsstrecke fertig sein
doch den trans kantabrier co lässt das
kalt der neue lokführer raúl gonzalez
will reisen und nicht rasen
wie viele tunnel hier wir fahren unter
bilbao hindurch aber jetzt kommen wir
gleich raus
der streckenabschnitt zählt zu den
erfahrensten der ganzen tour pendlerzüge
nah und fernverkehr alles tummelt sich
auf der schiene
das ist ein gefährlicher bahnübergang
fußgänger überqueren mitunter achtlos
die schienen für raúl der reinste horror
[Musik]
der zog lässt die stadt hinter sich und
fährt durch die berühmten baskischen
weinbaugebiete
die region heißt el país vasco und der
wein der von hier kommt heißt schakuri
der her
weinverkostungen spielen eine wichtige
rolle beim gesamterlebnis trans kann
publikum
einer dieser weine wurde dieses jahr als
bester weißwein der welt prämiert der
welt der welt ja nicht schlecht
unterwegs legte da öl einen halt ein er
fährt den stromabnehmer ein und schmeißt
seinen diesel motor wieder an
denn in den bergen gibt es keine
oberleitungen
vor uns liegen mehrere tunnel und viele
kurven
vermutlich erreichen wir santander mit
verspätung
die strecke ist einfach schwierig
und es wird noch schwieriger der trans
kantabrier co fährt direkt in eine
schlechtwetterfront
so knapp
der regen hat sich verzogen teddy
genießt die reise durch spaniens grünen
norden
in diesem zug geht es nicht um
geschwindigkeit sondern darum die
fantastische landschaft zu genießen die
dieser teil spaniens zu bieten hat
gerade überqueren wie einen fluss und in
der nächsten halben stunde werden wir
diesen noch fünf mal überqueren
der zweite teil der reise führt richtung
westen die biskaya entlang durch
flusstäler und über berggipfel
vor jeder kurve drosselt die
geschwindigkeit mit augenmaß und viel
fingerspitzengefühl
dieser zug ist schwerer zu fahren als
alle anderen in spanien hier muss der
lokführer sein ganzes können zeigen
die vegetation hier ist extrem dicht an
einigen stellen sieht es aus wie im
dschungel für die passagiere ist das
wirklich interessant und toll anzusehen
aber der lokführer muss hier immer voll
konzentriert sein
viel grün ganz nordspanien sieht so aus
überall
raúl fürchtet vor allem unterholz in
scharfen kurven
wir müssen auf alles vorbereitet sein
auf der letzten fahrt lag ein
umgestürzter baum auf den gleisen
dann geht es in den s creed tunnel er
ist knapp 1,5 kilometer lang und
einspurig züge durchfahren ihn in beide
richtungen
70 65 80 sprich die leitstelle
der bahn verkehr wird rund um die uhr
überwacht
hier sind für ganz nordwestspanien
zuständig das heißt für ein streckennetz
von 3000 kilometern
der trans kantable co ist einer von 400
zügen den die leitstelle in elbe ron
täglich auf dem schirm hat
wir kommen uns um probleme auf der
strecke signal ausfälle defekte loks und
wartungsdienst
die überwachung der züge und die signal
freigaben erfolgen in echtzeit um
kollisionen zu vermeiden
[Musik]
derweil nähert sich der luxuszug dem
hafen von santander und überquerten
carranza fluss
[Musik]
dieser zug ist nie langweilig er macht
spaß
[Musik]
bahnhof santander
nächste halt ist santander
angekommen
eine 170.000 einwohner stadt
für den morgigen tag ist regen angesagt
die crew des trans canta breko bereitet
sich auf eine unruhige fahrt vor
getrennt die lok fährt zum tanken
[Musik]
und bekommt eine ladung sand gegen nasse
gleise
[Musik]
der salzstreuer wird per hebel in der
lok gesteuert wie man sehen kann rieselt
der sand auf die schiene und sorgt so
für bessere haftung auf den gleisen
samuel prüft eine sicherheitsvorrichtung
unter dem waggon sie kann im zweifel
leben retten
es ist ein ganz wichtiges teil es gibt
eines unter jedem wagen um entgleisungen
zu vermeiden
wenn ein waggon zu entgleiten droht
signalisierte detector dies den anderen
waggons und aktiviert die notbremse für
den ganzen zug damit wird verhindert
dass weitere wagen entgleisen und es zu
einem schweren unfall kommt
auf der schmalspur ist die fahrt
holpriger das sicherheitssystem sorgt
dafür dass der zug im fall der fälle auf
den schienen bleibt
der abend klingt stilvoll mit
klassischer musik aus
[Musik]
währenddessen hat die schicht der
schienen arbeiter gerade erst begonnen
mit schwerem gerät wechseln sie
verschlissene schienen aus
mehr als 10 mm abnutzung sind nicht
tolerabel dann tauschen wir sie aus
das raue küsten klima setzt den gleisen
arg zu die regenzeit dauert hier sieben
monate
sind die gleise zu abgenutzt haben die
eisenbahn räder kein halt mehr
die maschine nimmt die alten gleise raus
und legt sie beiseite dann verlegt sie
die 9
jedes jahr werden große gleisabschnitte
erneuert und zwar nachts damit die züge
tagsüber rollen können diese art wartung
ist präventiv schließlich geht es um die
sicherheit der passagiere
früh am morgen in santander und wir sind
bereit zur abfahrt es geht ans meer an
die biskaya ausflüge sind auch geplant
der trans kantable co verlässt santander
und nähert sich einem kulturellen
highlight der reise
[Musik]
ein verborgenes juwel das aus der
steinzeit stammt
die höhle von altamira wird auch die
sixtinische kapelle der altsteinzeit
genannt sie wurde 1879 entdeckt aber
erst 2001 wurde diese rekonstruktion
erschaffen
die original höhle befindet sich nur
wenige meter entfernt doch sie ist nicht
zugänglich für die öffentlichkeit vor
ihrer entdeckung hatte niemand für
möglich gehalten dass die
steinzeitmenschen zu solcher kunst fähig
waren
die künstler von altamira hatten ein
gutes anatomisches verständnis der tiere
sie waren jäger die die tiere den ganzen
tag beobachteten und ein meisterhaft
abbildeten
die insgesamt 17 verzierten höhlen
erstrecken sich über fast 300 meter
sie haben viele gruppen ihr durchgeführt
was fasziniert sie
die unterschiedlichkeit der bilder die
verschiedenen techniken und tiere diese
gemälde sind 36.000 jahre alt
in der nähe der höhle liegt das alte
dorf santillana del mar mit seiner
prächtigen kirche
[Musik]
diese mittelalterliche stadt aus dem
achten jahrhundert ist noch heute
bewohnt die leute geben ihre häuser von
generation zu generation weiter
einzig das wetter spielt nicht mit
als die reisenden zum zug zurückkehren
schüttet es wie aus kübeln
ja
alles klar wir fahren
heute hat es viel geregnet
wir müssen vorsichtig sein
bei so viel regen können bäume oder auch
geröll auf den gleisen liegen
starker regen kann auch zu erdrutschen
führen
[Musik]
schau dir das mal an
manchmal sieht man vor lauter wasser die
gleise nicht mehr
wenn es zu heftig wird sperrt die
leitstelle die strecke
nico ist das gleisbett überflutet
ok schauen wir mal wie es aussieht
eventuell stoppen oder beschränken wir
den verkehr
weiter geht es zum nächsten stopp
jannis
wir hatten hier schon mehrere unfälle
vor ein paar jahren tauchte am ende der
kurve plötzlich eine familie auf
ich habe ein lautes signal und zog die
notbremse und sie sprangen zur seite
das war so knapp
doch heute verläuft alles nach plan bis
auf das wetter
ist das normal in nordspanien na klar
das grün gibt es nicht umsonst es muss
regnen damit die natur lebt das ist ja
das schöne an dieser landschaft
schließlich erreicht der trans
kantabrier co die wilde grüne küste
nordspaniens
hier am nordwestlichsten zipfel des
landes ist das kann publisher mehr nur
einen steinwurf vom zug entfernt
das ist eine der schönsten strecken auf
unserer route vom zug aussehen der
traumstrände klippen und wunderschöne
landschaft
auch technisch gesehen ist dieser
streckenabschnitt bemerkenswert neben
zahlreichen tunneln sticht die
spektakuläre kanalbrücke hervor sie
führt über den rio es war und rot auf
massiven betonpfeilern die mehr als zehn
stockwerke hoch sind
ich war ziemlich überrascht als ich
hörte dass dies hier eukalyptusbäume
sind typisches koala essen im
neunzehnten jahrhundert brachte ein
spanischer mönch die samen aus
australien mit und das klima ist perfekt
für sie und heute wachsen sie über
das feuchte meeresklima ist ein segen
für die vegetation sand hilft gegen
nasse rutschige schien doch die
sichtachsen offen zu halten ist eine
sisyphos arbeit
[Musik]
auf diesem abschnitt gibt es viele
kurven vielleicht zu viele wir müssen
die strecke sauber halten und dafür
sorgen dass die fahrer immer freie sicht
haben
zugewachsene gleise blockieren die räder
mindern die haftung und können bei
funkenflug sogar in brand geraten
für den lokführer markt das grün ein
problem sein für die reisenden ist es
jedoch ein bonus auf dieser
erlebnisreichen reise
[Musik]
von einem viadukt aus haben die
fahrgäste einen atemberaubenden blick
über das hafenstädtchen
da unten liegt die stadt was für ein
wahnsinns blick ins tal auch das meer
ist zu sehen morgen fahren wir die
galicischen küste entlang
früh am morgen geht's in die kleine
stadt riga die
sie ist der startpunkt für einen
weiteren spektakulären ausflug
[Musik]
die einheimischen nennen dies den strand
der kathedralen lägen seine
unglaublichen felsformationen sie sind
durch den mächtigen ozean und die wilden
atlantik winter entstanden
aus ganz spanien kommen die leute
hierher und fragen wer das erschaffen
hat
ein traum dieser tag ist ein geschenk
für uns
das heutige abendessen kommt
selbstredend aus dem meer
das gibt es heute zum dinner einen
felsen tisch für die caldera
[Musik]
schweren herzens geht's zurück zum zug
die gezeiten hier am strand sind extrem
bei flut steigt das wasser in kürzester
zeit auf 5 meter
da kommt sie schon
die seeluft macht hungrig das weiß auch
anderes der die meeresfrüchte zubereitet
wir sind hier am meer klar dass es heute
fisch und meeresfrüchte gibt
[Musik]
der zug setzt sich in bewegung und das
abendessen kann serviert werden
wie in jeder bordküche ist es auch hier
serie umso unglaublicher welche
delikatessen in diesem zug kreiert
werden
fangfrischer hunger
[Musik]
nach dem festmahl
wird der dancefloor eröffnet
was für eine großartige tanz party
[Musik]
auf den letzten kilometern macht sich
wehmut breit
wir sind fast da oder in etwa zehn
minuten erreichen wir für all
die schmalspur gleise enden in führung
weiter geht's nicht
nach acht gemeinsamen tagen an bord
fällt der abschied schwer
danke für alles rein was
für ein luxus nordspanien auf diese art
kennenzulernen tolle landschaft
köstliches essen ein erstklassiger zug
mit einem grandiosen team an bord
trans country clásico wow was für ein
trip